[Music]
spencer is with us in uh indiana to
start off this hour hey spencer what's
up
hey dave um i have quite a mess i've
made for myself
um but for what me and my wife are
working on trying to get out cool we're
on baby step two
and uh
i have a whole bunch of student loans um
i haven't consolidated them yet
partly because of the the way that
the repayment is right now everything's
kind of on forbearance
i've been making the minimum payment
despite the forbearance but
my question is this
i have a car loan
that's about thirty thousand dollars and
i have a bunch of student loans well i
have some student loans that are less
than thirty thousand
but my payment for my car is about 500
and
my payment for each of the student loans
are like
all together are about a thousand
dollars
and normally i
if i'm following your plan right i would
pay the smallest loans off first
but i'm just wondering if i'll have more
money to pay back with if i pay my car
off first
nope
works exactly the same math
math doesn't change
okay the um you're because
let's just pretend you're paying two
thousand dollars or three thousand
dollars a month on debt
okay
and then you're banking a a car payment
or you're not making a car payment
either one you're still going to plow
through the total of the debt in exactly
the same amount of time
it does not speed it up to get rid of
the big payment at all
the only thing that was speeded up is if
you got rid of a bigger interest rate
which is not what we teach but that
would actually speed it up
but paying but getting rid of the bigger
payment that you're making anyway
doesn't change a thing so what do you
guys make a year
um
320. well that's good
what do you do for a living
i'm a nurse anesthetist ah
and there's the student loans so yeah
what kind of mess did you make how much
is the student loan debt
right now it's at 275 atta boy
that's a lot what else what else
well i have uh we have
one of our cars is almost paid off we
have about five thousand left on it and
then our other car is about 30.
okay that's it student loans and cars
yeah well i mean we have a we have a
house we have a mortgage and we actually
have two houses one's getting rented out
but
we only have our mortgage but that's the
rest of our what's that what's that how
the rental house worth
uh it's worth maybe 200. what do you
want
about that we just
it was real like i said it's kind of
messy so
i would go ahead and get i would go and
get that sold
that's not a blessing that's a curse
well the reason i didn't sell it was
because i haven't had it for that long
i'm worried i'd pay a whole bunch of
taxes on it you're not paying taxes
you're not going to make any money okay
if you don't make money on it you don't
pay taxes
okay and was it a residence
yeah we we we were in it for just a few
months but how long have you been out
how long have you been out of it
uh about two months oh you can sell it
with no taxes at all
no matter what your profit is up to a
half million dollars married filing
jointly yeah you need to get rid of that
thing asap brother because it's it's uh
it's a vampire it is not going to do
anything except suck your blood
so you need to you need to be done with
that puppy and the um
and then from there
you know basically what we're dealing
with are the big numbers here
are we going to pay 150 a year on this
and be done in two years and have no
life
yeah and that's what i would
hope that's what i would prescribe
quit acting like you make a lot of money
and instead act like you're a broke
person because by the way you're a broke
person who actually
actually makes a lot of money
but uh uh which is wonderful great news
is you have a horrible hole that you're
in and you have a big old shovel to dig
out so that's wonderful
but i mean if you live on a hundred
thousand dollars a year and you put the
rest of it towards this day you could be
done in two years
that's what we're hoping yeah well it's
not hard
last year i was
yeah last year i was making
130 i think yeah 140 yeah
so
all right spencer spencer and we can get
better
spencer yeah
i'm going to ask you two questions right
in a row and just answer yes or no did
you take out 275 000 student loans
yes okay cool period that conversation's
over i can feel i can hear you walking
around your head staring at the ground
and you cannot get gazelle into a
gazelle can't run away with staring at
the of one foot in front of it because
it's going to trip and fall on its own
face hold your head up high you did it
it's over you own it and now we're going
to be about what comes next and now
you're a nurse anesthetist which makes a
butt load of money a ton of money
you you have people be alive yeah so now
go clean up the mess and in two years
you'll be done and you'll look back five
years from now with a big old pile of
money and you go god man i almost busted
it there thank god i decided to yes you
know lean into this yeah so lean into it
with a smile and go
be aggressive come on man game on get it
it is well i hope it just to hope it
works no no it's not going to get it
it's not smack it down it's math it's
not i it's not a wish by god it's math i
mean you make two you make 320 000 let's
put 150 a year on 275 and in two years
it's magically gone you know i mean it's
this is how it works but i and i don't
really care what your nurse anesthetist
friends are doing because they're
mathematically stupid so don't listen to
them okay i really don't care if they're
buying houses or bmws or whatever sell
the stupid house you just moved out of
get rid of it it's a problem it's not a
blessing
you can keep the cars just because you
make some stinking much money if you
want to keep that 30 000 car it's okay
if you're gonna get out of debt in two
years or less
if you're not going to get out of debt
in two years less and you sell the 30
000 car but you need to you you really
you really need to get out you need to
get this done
and you can do it
it's very
doable
now it's man i i i sometimes i talk to
people that have 275 000 in debt
and they make a hundred
or they make 65 and that that's a bigger
problem man i mean that's a little bitty
shovel in a big old hole you know you
can't you can't do that so
you know the good news is you have the
blessing of this income so you have to
dial it in and be
game on
committed you and your wife and go
we don't make 320 000 a year we're not
going to act like we make 320 000 a year
because we have a mess that is bigger
than this and we have to live on nothing
beans and rice rice and beans you don't
need to see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there you don't
need to go on vacation you need to get
out of debt and you can do it you can do
it you can do it
i can see it
and i can't wait to hear your debt-free
scream it's going to be amazing